[Music]
sarah is in louisville kentucky hi sarah
how are you
hi i'm i'm doing well how are you all
doing
great how can we help yes so i have a
question me and my husband
just got married in june and
we've been together for almost nine
years
and until i got off college so
we decided to get married and his um
his views on having the same or separate
bank accounts has changed
right before we got married basically
and
i guess what i wanted to ask you is what
do you suggest
or how do you think we can communicate
on
compromising on if we should have
separate or
the same accounts i personally would
rather have
a joint account because we're you know
we're married now
we're a couple we're one he feels that
we should have separate
why good question
i tried to ask him that and he
doesn't i don't know it's hard to
explain i guess he doesn't want to be
managed which like
um as far as
asking him why he spent his money on
this or that um not his money
yeah i was just about to say that
it's not what he's not his money and
it's not your money
yeah it's our money yeah if you want to
be independent you shouldn't get married
i told him that yeah i was like
you know i've like been you know
i just okay let me let me tell you let
me talk let's talk this through okay
jesus said jesus said your treasure is
where your heart is
where you spend your money is directly
refl
a direct reflection of what your views
on life are
what your value system is what your
fears are
what your dreams are and how you spend
your money reflects all of that
when a couple does not combine
their spending and their accounts
and their goal then they haven't
combined their goals
and they haven't combined their dreams
and they don't face the fears together
they're doing life as two roommates
which is what you did for nine years
that's the problem
uh and then uh but the uh uh
you know you haven't combined where
you're going and so communication is
down
and there's a high probably a much
higher probability of marital problems
and divorce in that situation
and the other piece of it is this out of
the 10 000 millionaires that we
interviewed
one of the things we found very very
consistently in the largest study of
millionaires ever done
was that they combined accounts and
worked together with their spouses and
their spouses were supportive and
cheerleading
yeah i agree they weren't pulling apart
and they were pulling each other
apart yeah
i agree it's weird it's i come from one
out of eight
he's the only child's grandchild so i
mean our
values and views are the same besides
of course the question i'm asking you
but
as far as that you know we try to work
together
well i think i think you need to get
some marital counseling yeah
that's what i think okay and have a good
someone that you can both trust
to speak into this whether it's your a
local pastor
or a good marriage counselor or someone
you can both get trust with
because the idea that you know i don't
want my wife telling me what to do
why don't my wife tell me what to do
either
and sharon doesn't want me telling her
what to do and so we lay out a game plan
together
that we both have a vote in and i don't
tell her what to do and she doesn't tell
me what to do we talk through it and we
both come to the same conclusion that
this amount of money is going for this
but i don't just wander off and go do
whatever the flip i want to do
and oh by the way sharon has not created
a personal income
her by herself that she created income
in 34 years
yeah all the income that comes into the
house i did but it's still
our money it's our income
and i treat it as if she created the
income
in terms of her vote is equal to mine
when we get ready to make a large
purchase when we get ready to make a
decision
we have to do it equal and um he
listen this is gonna be very difficult
for y'all
it's gonna it's gonna really hold you
back it's gonna be a stumbling block in
your communication and your
relationships if you don't solve it
i don't have a magic wand to make it go
away yeah and sarah
what you gotta do is you need to tell
them i mean actually go find a counselor
that's willing to meet with you all
and then come to him and say you know
can we can we just get some some wisdom
uh don't make it just about this make it
about hey we just want a healthy start
you know so that way he doesn't feel
attacked he doesn't feel like you're
just
trying to prove a point but say you know
what hey let's get some counseling let's
get some wisdom around our marriage so
how we could do this
start off on the right foot and then
bring that up in that situation
because dave here's my thing if if he's
having a problem with that
he's having some some other problems and
other things within their relationship
as well i agree
right and so i would definitely
recommend that sarah too
please listen to us get a counselor but
get a counselor for
everything not just one particular issue
yeah we
pretty much um one of the conditions of
me giving
a blessing for my one of mine getting
married was that they're gonna do
detailed in-depth pre-marriage
counseling
because they come from a weird family
yes
can you imagine being my kid yeah oh my
god
yeah what a what a blessing and what a
curse yeah yeah you know
and so or can you imagine marrying my
kid and having to put up with this
loudmouth family
that's got a lot of opinions though you
know you got so you got to get ready for
this stuff
and so if you're a single if you're a
only child and the only grandchild and
so you think you're special
well you're bringing problems to the
marriage yes you know if you're one of
eight and you're used to sharing
everything
maybe way too much yeah you might be
bringing problems to the marriage guess
what we all bring
problems to the marriage and learning to
work through those things
and so it's different like when you you
get married in your 30s
versus somebody getting married at 21.
it's a different game you're cause
you're kind of set in your way
you got your little system mr bachelor
yeah i'm selfish dave i know that and
and you know
it somebody gonna interrupt your system
you know that's gonna be that's gonna
require
some some discussion ah dave can you
move on past the subject
i'm over here like man dave is kind of
scared
i mean can you imagine
rachel cruz and winston cruz sitting in
pre-marriage counseling discussing dave
ramsey no
no not right now right now i can promise
you
it ain't all good yeah yeah okay i know
winston nah i know i know i'm a saint
and i know i'm perfect but other than my
other than my
narcissism
and this and i get it but you know
that's what you imagine i mean i don't
know dave but you know what the
problems that you can i mean we have
extra problems in this family because of
the
the celebrity status and the wealth and
the other stuff there's extra problems
you're coming into
more than just normal everyone to his to
sarah to anthony's point everyone has
something to unpack
absolutely i'm gonna have a lot to
unpack you know my brother's getting
married next month dave and
he actually did pre-marital counseling
before he engaged because he knew
that they both had a lot to unpack so
before they even said
yes let's get married they went to
counseling beforehand to see
if pre-marriage free yeah
and he said it was the best decision so
i said okay i'm gonna try that when i do
find one and
um i'm gonna try that as well yeah
because there is a lot that comes with
me i mean you're gonna have the same
exact thing because you're in the
spotlight
everybody knows who you are you've got a
huge social media following yeah
people recognize you when you're walking
down the street you know
and that's a weird thing to marry into
it is
it's a strange dynamic um and
you know so it's it's it's just a thing
so yeah and everybody's got something
like that so
and sarah in your husband's case it's
just that he thinks the top the axis of
the world runs through the top of his
head because his parents and
grandparents told him that
because he's the only one running around
nobody else running around
underfoot and that doesn't make him a
bad guy but uh
he he's gonna have to share for the
first time in his life yes
if he wants to be a good husband
that's just hey that that's not picking
on him we're all got stuff
we're sitting here unpacking our stuff
in front of you so there you go